Reading your email this week on glucose, glutamine seemed like going light on glutamine was a good idea. I have been not been told the restrict protein in my diet.
Should I be worried about it?
So I recommend that anybody with cancer never takes excess glutamine.
Why would you take excess glutamine?
Well, if you're using a lot of protein powder, you're going to get some glutamine.
But if it's a balanced protein powder, you're not going to get a ton of glutamine.
Where are you going to get the most glutamine?
Is it a supplement for your gut?
So gut healing supplements are going to be very high in glutamine.
About a glutamine in this bird band powder, most likely is maybe 300 milligrams, most likely, maximum.
Maybe far less than that.
But there's there's
glutamine products that are very high in glutamine, purposefully.
Why? Because glutamine drives growth.
And that's why it can be really, really good to heal your gut quickly. It drives growth.
Glutamine is what epithelial cells really feed off of.
So it can really help heal the gut.
Because damage got leaky gut syndrome is because there's a gap in the,
a gut epithelial cell has died.
So you're really reproducing gut cells so that you could heal those wounds in the gut, those,
those tight junctions that have been opened up because of damaged gut cells.
So what makes sense? Well, why should everybody be glutamine?
Because glutamine drives growth.
And if you have cancer, you certainly do not want to drive growth of any kind.
And secondly, there's, there's other negatives to be not a glutamine product too.
That has nothing to do with cancer. So if you have a lot of.
And if you have a lot of bad gene defects, then you are going to convert glutamine to glutamate quite readily.
And glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter.
And that can cause muscle twitching, muscle spasms.
But more serious than that, it functions in the brain as an excitatory neurotransmitter,
causes an increase anxiety, increases ADD, increases ADHD.
And good as eggs, we kind of have an epidemic of that in our society.
But it's partly because the food processing companies put glutamates in the food because glutamates fire on receptors on your tongue.
Excitatory neurotransmitters in the brain that cause an increase in uptake of excitement in the brain.
Literally, you can see on a functional MRI, your brain just literally light up when you put glutamates, how your tongue.
And that actually makes you think, ooh, this food tastes so good.
So the pleasure that you get from eating something with a lot of glutamates is increased.
You get this excitatory spike, kind of like a dopamine spike that you'd get from reading your emails or getting it to runners high.
You could get this glutamate spike, but it can be very damaging to the brain.
It could actually cause an increase in glutamate receptors on your neurons that never go away.
And you could really cause a lot of damage to this person can be that very prone to, you know, anxiety and OCD tendencies.
That is literally what OCD and anxiety is, is really a glutamate issue 99% of the time.
So adding exogenous glutamates are causing this issue and making it even worse for these people.
Adding exogenous glutamate, if you have a lot of, there's several different genes, GAN genes are just one of them.
You will break down glutamine, the amino acid in the glutamate quite quickly, way faster than you will spike your glutamates as well.
So there's some, yeah, there's some benefit to using glutamine in a nutritional supplement.
If you do not have cancer and you have leaky gut, but still even that, I would only do that a very short period of time.
I personally, so if I have a non-cancer patient and they have leaky gut issues and we're going to try to heal their leaky gut, I will use our clear GI product.
And that is, is got glutamated, if it's got a whole bunch of other slippery element, a whole bunch of other really good nutrients to help heal the gut, but it's only got, it's got less than a gram of glutamate.
So a lot of gut healing products will have five, four or five grams of glutamate.
I think it's very dangerous playing with that. I just don't think that's a good idea.
Even if you don't have cancer and a lot of people have cancer, they don't know they have cancer, they're just like pouring fire on the cancer fuel gasoline on a fire that they don't even know is burning, so it's very dangerous.